what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as we continue our discussion on DC
rebirth we are going to step back for a
second and we're going to run over the
rebirth issue of Red Hood and The
Outlaws and again I realize I'm a little
behind here but the idea is to basically
play catch-up and to run over these
various rebirth issues for the sake of
simply just having them so that when we
come along to the individual character
story arcs later on down the line we
don't have to go back and retell the
rebirth issues we can literally just
reference them for videos they can that
people can watch later on but what's
really ironic about this is that this is
called Red Hood and The Outlaws but it
really just focuses on Red Hood and that
makes sense you know of course Red Hood
and The Outlaws are against the outlaws
concept was a new 52 idea launched by
Scott Liddell and it was basically a way
to give Red Hood his own sort of team
ought to give him a group of individuals
who were for all intents and purposes
anti-heroes and then have them act out
their various adventures accordingly of
course a Red Hood of the outlaws was
written by Scott Liddell and so it's
good to see him returned to the Red Hood
title now but for those of you guys who
don't really know much about Jason Todd
the beauty of this rebirth issue is that
because rebirth as a whole is a way to
blend what worked with a new 52 with
what worked in the pre new 52 this is
really just taking Red Hood as we knew
him before the new 52 and just kicking
off from there it's almost as if Scott
l'hotel is basically eliminating
everything from the new 52 with regards
to the outlaws and and that's kind of
the cool thing here is this basically to
sort of a refresh it's not really a
reboot so much as a let's wipe the slate
clean with aspects of Jason Todd's
character and let's go forward from
there and so this is kind of like a take
2 for the the outlaws idea and again you
know because of the fact that this was
designed to be a jumping-off point for a
lot of new readers but Scott Lowe do
basically refreshes us with the idea of
Jason Todd now for those of you guys who
are well versed in his history bear with
me for a second because again I know
there are a lot of people out there who
are not when it came to the idea of
Jason Todd
he has a long running history in Batman
but he's really the result of fans
killing him that's the best way to put
it uh you know when Dick Grayson first
appeared
DC Comics he changed comic books forever
I did grace and introduce the idea of
teenagers fighting alongside superheroes
the sidekick and because of this it
actually tripled Batman sales in fact
assuming you could find the data for it
online which there are locations where
you can go and find the information I
did Grayson's introduction resulted in
one issue of Detective Comics prior to
his introduction running you know one of
the mill doing a standard sales release
in terms of publications and then after
Dick Grayson the publications tripled so
you could actually measure how
successful Dick Grayson was for the
Batman franchise but because the fact
that Dick Grayson had grown so popular
and because sidekicks had become such a
huge thing in the realm of not just DC
but by you know timely and Atlas which
would become marvel at this point in
time it resulted in sidekicks being
everywhere and so DC said okay well
let's give him their own team and they
launched the Teen Titans the result was
that for time you saw Dick Grayson
walking both a line of Batman or I guess
Batman's sidekick as well as being on
Teen Titans but eventually he left the
side of Batman and was was Teen Titans
in his entirety and the result was that
Bruce Wayne went back to being his own
solo superhero the problem with this was
that the the fruit hadn't tasted you
know people liked the idea of Batman
having a sidekick because it grounded
him it took Bruce Wayne away from being
just this guy that went in fought
vigilantes too now he's got to look
after a sidekick and it gave him a
reason to sometimes run away from a
fight not because he wanted to but
because it was in the best interest of a
sidekick it also gave us the rainbow
Batman suit and of course that's never a
bad thing and so what what the
introduction of Jason Todd did and the
events before crisis on Infinite Earths
and following crisis on Infinite Earths
as it saw the second sidekick of Batman
being introduced the issue with this was
that when Jason Todd first showed up
pre-crisis his origin story was
identical to Dick Grayson and fans hated
that fan said this is ridiculous
Dick Grayson has his own origin story if
you're going to introduce a second
sidekick give him his own story and so
following crisis on Infinite Earths
Jason Todd got his own origin story but
the damage had been done you know in the
eyes of fans Jason Todd was a cheap
attempt to replicate Dick Grayson and it
have anything to do with him and so DC
effectively killed off Jason Todd at the
request of fans and they did so by
having the Joker murder him now again we
basically get a lot of this stuff over
the course of the opening issue it's
found Odell pays special attention to
the idea to the relationship between
Jason Todd and Bruce Wayne innocence
that Jason Todd in the eyes of Bruce was
a kid who was lost he was a kid that was
falling down the rabbit hole of crime
and it would eventually most likely get
himself killed because of what he was
doing the fact that he was actually
jacking the wheels off off the Batmobile
which takes some balls to be honest it
takes balls to uh to leave the Batmobile
on cinder blocks but the fact remains
here what an awesome thing to do what an
awesome idea but the fact remains here
that you know with Bruce Wayne taking
Jason Todd under his wing he became the
second Robin and what was interesting
about his character at least you know
and you know to my mind anyway was that
Jason Todd was much darker he wasn't
really like Damian Wayne dark he was a
great blend between how ruthless Damian
Wayne is and the nature of Dick Grayson
in terms of being almost identical to
Batman and so because of this there were
times where it was alluded to and he was
even shown on a couple of occasions that
Jason Todd let people die whether it was
dropping them to their deaths or else
killing them outright
he Sheree was shown to be a very brutal
character in a lot of different aspects
now ultimately when it came to his death
it really changed everything
it changed the entirety of how Batman
saw sidekicks because now it was the
fact that it wasn't just enough to keep
him safe he had to keep them out of
harm's way and for a time he didn't want
any sidekicks and he was even gave the
cold shoulder to Dick Grayson and you
know Scott Liddell focuses on a lot of
this now the other half of this is that
Scott Liddell focuses on the here and
now Scott Liddell focuses on the moment
because again all the rebirth issues are
designed to not only give us a refresher
of who the characters are and what
direction they're going to go in but
they're also designed to set the stage
for the coming stores and so for Red
Hood in the outlaws this is basically
just setting the stage for for the
character over for where we're going
what direction we're going to see Jason
Todd going in but again what this does
is it shows us that
you know in the midst of you know I
guess Gotham City at the moment that
Jason Todd seems to be hunting down the
mayor of Gotham and this is done in a
way to where it's it's almost as if we
get bits and pieces and truth not much
happens in this story it's quite
literally Jason Todd just tracking down
the mayor and then Batman shows up and
Batman you know and Jason Todd began to
get into a fight with one another but
it's also Scott Liddell showing us what
Jason Todd is capable of it's he on the
same level as Dick Grayson in terms of
fighting prowess no is he on the same
level as Damian Wayne not at all does
that mean that he is a weak character no
it doesn't because what he even says it
himself what he has now is experience
under his belt because he spent time
fighting you know fighting alongside
Batman
he knows what Batman is about now again
because Scott Liddell is telling us
what's happening in the present moment
with red hood while simultaneously
telling us his backstory he also shows
us that when DC decided to kill author I
guess when the fan base decided to kill
off Jason Todd when he was effectively
beat to death by the Joker and I guess
when he was beat by the Joker and left
to die in an explosion it resulted in
him being taken to the Lazarus pits of
Ra's al Ghul and being resurrected
following that you know of course we saw
the story under the Red Hood I think it
was called under the Red Hood which led
into him returning to Gotham City
enigmatically no one really knew who he
was cutting a swath in the criminal
underworld in an attempt to find and
kill the Joker now of course that is a
beautifully written story and I may
cover it for classic DC day because
under the Red Hood is like the
definitive Red Hood story when it comes
to when it comes to Jason Todd I think
you'd be hard-pressed to find anybody
who would say that there's a better
story than that um it was it was pretty
damn good but we also again get a little
bit of exposition here a little bit of
explanation in the sense that um you
know Jason Todd after presumably
shooting the mayor is contacted by what
appears to be a member of
black mass now black mask isn't really
like he's not like the Red Skull you
know I mean they seem similar in
appearance but they're they're
completely different black mask is
really more of a guy who runs a criminal
empire but he's not nearly
he doesn't really operate on like a
global scale like Red Skull does instead
black mask actually just wears a mask to
keep his face hidden but the idea is to
operate from the shadows the idea is to
never really be caught with his hand in
the cookie jar which is similar to Red
Skull but he also has his own agents
carrying out his own will but because of
the fact that he operates with the
notion of the false faith Society which
are basically people whose identities
cannot be verified by way of people you
know looking at them you know not being
able to see their faces red hood is
brought into the fold or at least asked
to join the fold now we learn that the
reason behind this is because again he's
very much pursuing the criminal
underworld and while Batman initially
tries to talk him out of it he says the
only way to really do this is to go
underground and to become part of the
criminal empire the way to become part
of the criminal empire is to engage in
activities with very seedy individuals
not for Bruce Wayne he doesn't want to
see this happen because he knows how
easy it can be to reach that point of no
return but all it takes is one false
step all it takes is one bad move and
truth if we wanted to reference the
Joker we could say all it takes is one
bad day but it results in the fact that
the character of Jason Todd would end up
crossing a line that he can't come back
from
and so again he says you know you have
to trust me on this you have to trust me
on this idea that I know what I'm doing
you have to trust me on the fact that
yes I'm going to be doing some seedy
things yes I'm going to be fighting
alongside some seedy people but in the
end it's all for the greater good and I
promise you I will not fall to the
wayside no this is kind of an ironic
statement by both Jason Todd and Batman
because with Jason Todd initially making
his appearance and seeming as though he
was a vigilante seeming as though he was
out to basically take over Gotham City
is very ironic then he would come back
and say I'm essentially going to be
doing the exact same thing but I'm not
for Bruce Wayne though it's also the
recognition that while he has engaged in
some relatively bad activities and while
vo of course Dick Grayson was a spy at
one point in time and even now is
operating or I guess you know prior to
the to the events of
that man was operating as part of the
Parliament of owls which was the global
version of the court of owls from
Snyder's run of Batman that even Bruce
Wayne himself recognized how easy it was
to fall and so again it's really not
necessarily the Bruce Wayne who's trying
to get in the way of Jason Todd so much
as it is that he's trying to make sure
that he doesn't end up tumbling down
this rabbit hole of self-destruction and
so it's it makes for a pretty compelling
case when it comes to the relationship
between the two because of the fact that
it is so unique I mean following the
death of Jason Todd and his resurrection
the relationship between the two was
just never the same it was never the way
it had been before it was one of the few
relationships that Batman had with his
robins were aided stretched to the point
whereby there was no measure of
reconciliation there was no possibility
of things going back to the way they
used to be with the other Robins new man
bad girl it can to a degree they look at
him they respect him especially after
the events of death of the family when
it came to Snyder's run and Joker's
assault on the entire bat family there
was still some measure of reconciliation
there but for Jason Todd that's not a
possibility for Jason Todd that's that's
never gonna happen so anyway guys I know
this was kind of a weird explanation
it's not usually like the ones that we
normally do but that's because of the
fact that we're literally referencing a
character that DC is sort of removing
the new 52 landscape from and focusing
almost entirely on the pre new 52
concept and then just sort of going from
there but it's also because of the fact
that I felt like in a video like this
when we're talking about you know a DC
we birth issue of such a pivotal
character from DC's landscape I feel
like it was more important to really
focus on the past of Jason Todd where he
came from why he's significant why fans
love him so much
as opposed to focusing on this very
moment of course you will have been able
to see everything that was happening in
the present day but the fact remains
here that I think this is really more of
setting the stage and showing us or
reminding us as readers what Jason Todd
is about so that we can go forward into
the existing story arc with red hood in
the outlaws knowing what's going on so
anyway guys if you guys are if you're
new here to comics explain be sure to
hit the subscribe button become part of
the Rob core if you guys like this video
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment down below because I'm kind of
curious of all the Robins that exists
and I'm really gonna be I'm gonna ruffle
some feathers with this with this
question with all the Robins that have
existed Kerry Kelly Stephanie Brown Dick
Grayson Tim Drake you know Jason Todd
Damian Wayne which one do you guys
prefer the most which one do you guys
think is the best because I'm curious
you know to see like yeah that's that's
question which Robin is the best Robin
all-around combat skills detective
skills the whole nine yards which one do
you guys think is the best and I will
catch you all in it peace
[Music]